مجددا يؤكد فلودي ميرسي لانسكي ان الصاروخ
الذي سقط في بولندا روسي استنتاجات قال
انها مبنيه على تقارير من الجيش الاوكراني
اعتقد انه كان صاروخا روسيا بناء على
تقاريرنا العسكريه
اما حلف شمال الاطلسي فرجها فرضيه ان تكون
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه اطلقت الصاروخ
حتى
الانظمه دفاع جوي او صواريخ اوكرانيه ولكن
مره اخرى هذا ليس خطا اوكرانيا روسيا
تتحمل مسؤوليه ما حدث في بولندا
اعتبر ان سقوط الصاروخ في بولندا
ايد البيت الابيض فرضيه ان الصاروخ الذي
ضرب هولندا اطلق من الدفاعات الاوكرانيه
لكن وزير الدفاع الامريكي اكد ان
التحقيقات مستمره
بولندا واخرين لجمع المزيد من المعلومات
وشركائنا
غداء تسقوط صاروخ في بولندا اثار مخاوف من
تصعيد النزاع في اوكرانيا استدعت وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه السفيره البولندي لدى
موسكو